for some 20 years the European Union has
been partnering with more than a hundred
countries to achieve the biggest impact
we build partnerships based on results
they are called budget support budget
support is a platform for dialogue
between the EU and its partners whereby
we align our priorities and discuss the
best way to achieve them it provides
countries with additional fiscal space
to finance their policies initiate
reforms deliver results and build their
capacities by working through partner
systems the European Union makes these
stronger and allows countries to sustain
results to tell you the approach three
types of budget support contracts are
available the sustainable development
goals contract is supportive and
national development strategy addressing
several SDGs the sector reform
performance contract which targets one
sector policy in particular and the
state and resilience building contract
intended for post crisis situations and
countries in situations of fragility
there are four general conditions to
benefit from EU budget support first and
foremost put forward a credible and
relevant strategy for national
development or for sector reforms second
maintain a stable macroeconomic outlook
or in case of Chris's take action to
restore key balances
third demonstrate progress in public
finance management and domestic revenue
mobilization fourth allow for budget
transparency and oversight
accountability involves regular audits
by the supreme audit institution
empowerment of the national parliament
and concrete actions to tackle
corruption accountability calls for
public data and strong statistical
systems to measure results the inclusion
of citizens little society and
businesses is key for long term success
programs will typically be concluded
within three years although some may be
shorter or longer multiple programs can
be implemented in a country at the same
time budget support consists of fixed
and variable tranches fixed tranches are
subject to four general conditions
variable tranches are contingent on
additional performance indicators which
will determine their disbursement rate
the EU offers expertise and dedicated
support to help with policy
implementation and to upgrade capacities
when a partner meets conditions results
are rewarded with financial transfers
into the nation's budget according to
the progress achieved funds are used
according to national procedures but the
EE requires countries to continue
opening their books and data we want
nations to grow people to flourish and
our planet to be protected we can help
with budget support let's talk